I'm a proud Canadian and I couldn't
think of anything better to go down to
Rio and represent my country ma'am may
be headed to Rio but one thing that
won't make it to Brazil is his trademark
facial hair now that he's rocking a new
clean shaven look but he has a good
reason for buzzing the beard the reason
I took it off the only reason really is
cuz i couldnt really Kyle with my kids I
got closed up to eight month old twins
it feels good but it feels like there's
a part of you kind of miss and take gram
may like lighting up the links but he
once had his sights set on the ice my
whole life I wanted to be a hockey
player that was it but I was not good
enough at that unfortunately I've got a
great family my family and also
Paulina's family whose Gretzky's which
everyone's familiar with up here in
Canada yes Dustin Johnson may be making
a name for himself in golf but his
future father-in-law is hockey legend
Wayne Gretzky Dustin and Gretzky's
daughter Paulina have a son together and
it sounds like his dad would be happy
with his baby boy picking up either a
golf club or a hockey stick he can do
whatever he wants if he wants to play
golf that's awesome come on and play
hockey and better I'll support him and
whatever he wants to do Dustin may be
walking the fairway in Ontario this
weekend but when it comes to walking
down the aisle he's leaving the planning
to the ladies of the family that's up to
Pauline and Jenna so whenever they tell
me to show up I'll be there
the Canadian fans are truly amazing and
we support our athletes like nobody else
in the world ontario native David Hearn
competes this weekend in the Canadian
Open and then he too is on the road to
Rio I'm excited about I can't wait to
get down to Rio and compete and try to
bring them out of home whether he'll
take gold remains to be seen but david
has already earned the distinction of
making our hottest golf around up that's
all right I can handle that you know I
thought something I've really thought
about before but I'll accept it over the
years has been blessing to have those
those people in my life that have been
there in the good times and I've Mike
Weir is easily Canada's most successful
golfer and though it's been a while
since he had a major win he's just happy
to still be in the game my perspective
now is different my success for me is
being happy and having balance in my
life and you sure I want play great golf
but it's not it's not everything to me
anymore